this is the theme the danger this is the
thesis the d miss mulatto hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be unto you welcome
to another episode of the Dean show and
in the D show studio we have sheikh abu
taubah who went from being a Christian
to a Muslim and you go to the D show com
we've done some shows with him in the
past and we talking about his
experiences his journey to Islam Islam
the simple message to acquire peace by
submitting to the one God the owner
peace the same God of Jesus Abraham Noah
Moses and all the messengers got
including the last and final messenger
the problem on the peace be upon him so
we're going to continue on talking to
him and having him share his experiences
with us when we come back here on the D
show sit tight
this is the theme but heed you this is
the phase is the teacher this is the
thing is this is the theme
assalamualaikum waalaikumsalam allah
peace be unto you Is ekalaka medical oh
oh yeah thank you thank you very much
all right you know we were continuing on
we've done some shows with you in the
past talking about your story how you
came to Islam people go to the Dean show
calm and we did kind of like a series
where you know it's very interesting
talking with you and we kind of went off
on some other elements and we discussed
that kind of here there but we still
didn't get to the crust of the matter
where we left off you were you joined
the Marines and you started to perform
the prayer and then that's where we kind
of left off if you can just take it away
we just slide right into it hamdulilah
balada mean salatu salam al Osuna hill
cream my alley he was ugly he one minute
about your my team you know when I was
in Japan it's very may sound strange
when i moved to japan i started to learn
more about Islam you know I went to the
masjid in japan and the imam there began
to teach me arabic how to read arabic so
the first letter he showed me and I
accused him of being a worshipper of
Muhammad i went to the message and I
said you know I want to learn about
Islam but I don't want to worship
Mohammed nice oh you Arabs you worship
Mohammed he was Arab lead the Imam and
so he's like no you know I said I said
yes you
do because every time you say Allah you
don't say anything but then when you say
Mohammed you say so love I Lahey what's
up yes you know a lot the one more right
for you say something after his name
like a lobby great is a lot and this
that and everything he said no really
Allah doesn't need anything he is gonna
need you like I mean he's free of all
need worthy of all praise where's the
Prophet Muhammad as a man he's a prophet
and he benefits from our prayer now we
pray for to Allah that Allah have mercy
on him and give him this high position
so I'm i immediately started to
understand something desperate so I said
I don't trust you because remember I
wanted to learn more about the religion
so you need to teach me arabic so i can
read for myself and figure this thing
out so he asked me my name my last name
robertson so he showed me the little raw
this is raw in Arabic he wrote it there
because I see this and it's lying above
says uh raw okay i can say that raw and
then the next letter he showed me was
bad see like your name and i thought he
was going to do my name he said Rob can
you say that I said yes I could say that
Rob he said this is a word you read your
first word was a very important word I
said what is this word he said Lord this
word is Rob Lord and it touched me the
way he did it made me cry I was like wow
so holla I'm reading and it's the first
word I ever read was Rumble you know and
said I had a lasting effect on my
insulin now I was in the Marine Corps as
you said and I was in Special Operations
I was part of an anti-terrorist team so
I know a lot about what terrorism is and
what it's not you know and hungry let
her be like mean so I was in a class and
during his class our teams was JSOC
Joint Special Ops capable so you have a
team of force recon a team of Navy SEALs
the team of Delta Force and we'll all
make one JSOC unit Joint Special Ops
capable of doing anything so we're
having this class and the screen pops on
and it says this is the first type of
terrorists and it was Yasser Arafat he
is the political
terrorists and so we're taking notes
down and then he said here goes the next
screen pops up here's the next terrorist
this is the religious fanatic and it was
I out to LA home a knee so we write this
down I got along he's the religious
fanatic and then in this screen pops
again and it shows more Monica dha'fi
and he is the military fanatic boom and
so the lights come on and they say hey
what are all these guys have in common
and somebody yells out there are
ragheads you know and so a couple of
guys giggling stuff like that and it
struck that he does and he says yeah
they're all Muslim okay then he says do
we have any Muslims in here and I raised
my hand my hand went up automatically
you know since I put my hand up so they
used to call me Rob because my last name
is Robertson are robbed or mr like that
so they say what type of Muslim are you
okay that was the key sentence that
changed my life what type of Muslim are
you I had never thought about it before
I never considered that thing and I
looked at the screen and it's got the
religious fanatic the political fanatic
and military fanatic those are the only
choices that I was given at the time so
I said I guess I'm the military fanatic
because you know we're all you know
military guys at that turn and everybody
bust out laughing uh uh uh you're a
funny guy they thought I was joking and
I said well you know what type of Muslim
am I for real I wasn't laughing you know
because I didn't know how to really
answer that question I knew there was
more to it than the three choices that I
had and that became the quest that I was
on the journey that was one to define
what type of Muslim am I so the logical
next question is what type of Muslims
are there what are the choices yeah yeah
let's let's take a break we're going to
we're going to continue their what are
the choices because you'll see a lot of
different you know amedee he you'll see
the what else you have the bra nation
the nation of islam you have the
different forms that islam is taking
over the years yeah you know so this is
a good point now and I'm
there's a lot of other people who can
relate to this we're going to continue
this what kind of Muslim are you now we
come back here on the D show do not feel
a woman do not kill a child do not you
know going to different religious
leaders Buddhism Hinduism forms of
Christianity I even ran into people from
the nation of the slap feeling very mad
you will not feel an animal you will not
cut a tree down do not create the water
do not burn their homes back here on the
Dean show and we're talking to abu
taubah and you hit a point where what
kind of muslim are you now before that
you would learn in arabic and you were
almost at the point where you're saying
like look you know let you know hit
little oh there's no god but the one guy
but you want to kind of seemed like
leave this muhammad the hadith out you
know right that's what it seems like to
me it what and we know that you know
there's no separation until the ground
verbatim word of god and you have the
sooner the authentic i say these aren't
lullaby stories these are the authentic
hadith sayings of the last final measure
because he's the walking her arm right
yes so now you you you are confused and
many people are because they don't have
the correct knowledge so now you have by
high you have a midi he you have my deep
dark beer yeah let's go take you so now
i'm trying to figure out what type of
muslim am i and you I started to do some
research to figure out I went asking
people and I started learning the
history of Islam in the United States
yes and so you have the those people
like the Nation of Islam or even before
that you have prints or masonry you have
the more science temple this group of
guys who saw themselves as African and
since African was meant Muslim to them
and they made this group and then they
started to go for and they have problems
in there they believe they made their
own quarter and you know and they make
blasphemy since I know these guys are
way out i'm not going to get myself
involved in that group right here then
you have the Nation of Islam who said
that Elijah Muhammad became the
messenger of allah from a statement
saying that he was you know fard
Muhammad is the god in person I said
it's the same thing as Christianity
there's nothing
different from that and I let go of that
and then it was this thing with the
wealthy Mohammed ministries and that was
really a more afro centric sighs you
know approach to its lab and I said well
you know to be a nationalistic is not
what Islam is calling me to be you know
I'm not going to be a reverse racist in
Islam and I want the proper religion of
Islam you know and I said to myself I my
father and my mother they weren't really
too happy when I accepted his lab and I
loved my father and I loved my mother as
I would never make my mother and father
displeased are unhappy for something
less than the truth and so I would read
the Quran and I like you said I
initially said well I don't really I
believe that Muhammad is the Messenger
of Allah but I don't know about these
hadith I don't want to get involved and
it's this may be just like the new
testament to me but then as I start kept
researching and finding out that no
Muhammad is the Messenger of Allah and
that that means that we believed
everything he said to us you know that
we have to take sacred law from him and
obey his commands and call everything
that he calls Haram and so I started to
learn more about what that meant can you
equate it can you equate it like if you
were living during the time of Moses he
was revealed the taurah and he was
explaining to the people how to
implement the Tehran well what happened
is I learned in Japan this happens in
japan now I learned what the Imam they
have made us do research papers on the
simple principles of Islam what is a
prophet that's what changed my life with
regards to the prophet mohamed salah
salem the prophet Mohamed Salah what is
a prophet a prophet is a man whom Allah
reveals to him revelation and tells him
what's going to happen in the future
what happened in the past and he tells
them how to rule the rule in the lives
of the people now what's a messenger a
messenger is a prophet that comes with a
new legislation he comes with a new book
if you want to use an example you have
the prophet moses and harun whereas
they're brothers Moses is a prophet and
a messenger he has a book revelation and
a Sharia legislation to rule in the
lives of the people where her own is a
prophet but he's not a
ginger he prophesizes and he has or has
the permission to lead the people and
teach them how to run their lives but it
doesn't have a new legislation or a book
that's revealed to him specific giving
any new laws so when I learned about
what was a prophet and what were the
rights of the prophets I did two things
I looked at Paul of sources in
Christendom and realized that he was not
a prophet and didn't have any right to
legislate okay second I looked at Jesus
and recognize that we don't really have
what he legislated in the Bible at all
and that made me understand why the
Quran was revealed and that the job of
the Prophet salah salem was to explain
the quran and i was very happy with that
because then i started to notice things
that i had known in Christianity that it
said going a little further Jesus falls
on his face in praise I said oh he's
making salah like we do you know and I
said well I didn't realize those
particular things until I started to
learn more about the Quran and how to
offer Salah and these types of things I
was able to bring things together but
then that still didn't answer my
question what type of Muslim I saw the
Shia Muslims and they were beating
themselves in the backs and we were
dealing with them because we were
fighting them at that time in the Marine
Corps so we see the Shia and I said well
these this is not the Islam that I know
about and they were saying that Ali was
the prophet of allah and i knew that was
incorrect and they were saying that
different from Sahaba were not to be
listened to the ruffed that this
mentality so I said okay we're not like
this then I heard about that aha Medea
then I heard about the the fuqua Rock
you know Chris coming from New York we
have this militates type Islam that was
grown in the United States we called it
the dolly slam and a daughter slab is
was a lot of the afro centric brothers
who started to practice his nap but it
was really heavily militant at the time
this war our fathers in an hour father
in law's so I said okay what's missing
all this Afrocentricity all this
militants all this too so woof where is
the Sun then like I said the prophet
mohamed salah salem became very
important at that time
and so I realized that the only way you
can be a good Muslim the thing that ties
Islam and the Quran all together is
following and emulating the life of the
prophet summer lovin slm the Prophet
Muhammad as as you said he is the
quarter and walking this is the last and
final message sent to mankind not Elijah
Muhammad no not i don't mean Elijah
Muhammad without my prophet muhammad the
son of abdullah ok so now you have to
follow him what about some people say
look you know we didn't get a proper
sent to us and this fraud Muhammad you
know and Elijah Muhammad and they sent
for the African Americans to help us and
they take him as a prophet well you know
what we tell those people is that you
know what's the difference between that
and Jesus and the idea that Jesus is God
as man you say father Muhammad is God in
the body map of man the Prophet Muhammad
different from all the other prophets
came down rotten little al-amin as a
mercy for all the people and so
different from jesus jesus said he came
only for the lost people lost sheep of
the children of israeel where's the
prophet muhammad sallallahu lemn he came
as a guide for all mankind for Chinese
black for every bevery box you can use
that excuse now in fact we find that the
majority the Muslims are Arab yeah you
know the majority the Muslims would be
the the Indonesian Malaysian people and
then the African people and then the
Indian people you know is so and then
you go to the outer people and find the
majority note we talk about Muslims you
know in immigrant in general but the
marriage set is that the Prophet
Muhammad is only for Arabs yeah this is
this is ludicrous so now what happens
next well I'm the liar balada mean I
come back to the United States I study
for some years here and I was teaching
in the United States and then I go back
overseas for about 10 years I lived in
Mauritania for 10 years I lived in morn
attaining for about six years six years
and then I moved to Egypt were you doing
there I was learning I was perfecting my
skill in Arabic language and a solo trip
ok law learning law and then I went to
Egypt and I memorized the Quran marcela
and then after that
sudden he got sick he had to have brain
surgery so I came back to the United
States and that was about three years
ago and I've been here I opened up
school called the fix fundamental
Islamic knowledge and seminary I teach
from the I teach Arabic i teach quarter
and memorization of the Quran and Laura
I do that now and you know have a book
coming out called the blackest black
sheep it chronic Eliza this whole
journey like that and that's pretty much
what we do and we do martial arts and
I'm gonna beat you up when i get a
chance here you bastard pishella we're
gonna have to you you know do a program
on that and since you know that's one
thing i didn't mention that you're also
involved in martial arts somewhat a
little bit yeah humble of how long you
been doing that well actually I've been
doing martial arts since the 70s since I
was a young youngster ya know hamdullah
I do a system now called el muro ah yeah
which is just you know the Islamic
system of chivalry Islam promotes people
taking care of themselves and especially
for the young adults and the old adults
to learn how to wrestle and that's what
martial arts is basically is wrestling
heard you do martial arts yourself yes
yes you know what do you do the gracie
brazilian jiu-jitsu Gracie Laos panel la
masha'Allah I heard the Gracie family is
really tight very tight very tight yes
yes and I will famous it so you just be
must be pretty good yeah hamdullah
tumblow I got involved with them and you
know they dominated the martial arts
world yeah you know a long time ago and
was a helio gracie the older one Helio
Gracie and then you have his brother
Carlos Gracie okay I'm under Carlos
Gracie from junior senior I mean junior
and I have the lineage connected back to
them shall ask that's a beautiful thing
I try to promote brothers to go learn
martial arts for Muslims because and you
don't have to get involved in the shark
and the different things that come along
with some of the systems yeah you know
and people have to realize that the
Muslims are very involved in martial
arts and that's another form of you know
internal struggle yeah where you're
you're not fighting the other guy but
you're fighting to see if you yourself
to make your body respond in a proper
way that will benefit you and training
your body and this
in yourself and what do you think about
that you know how do you find martial
arts in that regard I think it's
incredible definitely a good way to you
know channel your time in a positive way
in a constructive way we'll see if
you're afraid or not into some martial
arts I'm going to get eddies and do them
a karate chop inshallah we'll see how
tough years when we get on the mats and
I might take you up on that we're going
to take a break and we right back with
more here on the Dean show what slip boy
I got em be bringing on my ring I sing
for my Muslim boys and my sisters do
with everything for the sake of him
Allah when i'm in need of anything I
turned to him Allah success is what he
brings over here with sheikh abu taubah
and we're gonna bring you another
self-defense tip what do you say that's
good I like self-defense tips let's do
it so this week I've got round like this
would he get into now okay you see he's
grabbing me by my collar okay and now
from here I've tried to defuse the
situation it's not working now I know
defusing the situation now he put his
hands on I gotta defend myself okay so
how am I going to do it and suffer the
least amount of damage because again
I've tried to defuse is now working okay
so from here I'm going to grab the wrist
alright this is a bent arm escape if the
arm is stiff this won't work so it's a
bent arm escape I grab the wrist okay
and from here I'm going to step through
pop the elbow up duck under free hands
going to come over this is the sweet
self defense tip with eddie when i'm in
need of anything I turn to him
Allah success is why even though what
symbol of from South London they don't
even know what it means is to do for
them imma put it on a fake fur reason
they need to stop Viking enough in the
head of grieving don't diss me back
that's always the time i'm already
suffering and i'm already on the
straight line i'm already one God
worship Him alone do what he wants you
to do put your desire is this thing
inside you that just wants this and
wants that and you just can't get enough
you know what you never get enough until
the dirts in your mouth don't let it
come to that be sincere and honest ask
the one who created you to guide race
the first step put off chasing all the
women and the good times and the parties
and this and that there is no one would
be a voice chip except a lot don't wait
you never know if this would come today
for you
back here on the Dean show and wrapping
up we're almost out of time so tell us
now you had a long journey and how could
people now really benefit and take home
some great advice when either they are
Muslim or they've just been kind of
going with the flow and you have some
new Muslims how really people get to
practicing Islam the way that it was
revealed from the crater of the heavens
and earth to the last and final mystery
prob Muhammad peace be upon them so they
can input a minute the way that is
pleasing to the crater that observe and
they're not following their lusts and
desires and making up things as they go
along what advice do you have and how
many lat you know that's a good question
because at how did Allah we have
resources in like dr. bilal philips he
has his website Jamal's our bozo these
guys they have on the Internet where
people at home can go and get online and
ask questions from people who have gone
and studied and acquired a lot of
knowledge and now they're able to give
that knowledge back you know I try to
tell people don't get involved so much
with you know who is this person on it
and off it because there's a bunch of
people to get overly involved in that as
opposed to looking for benefit learning
the basics you know and then of course
you have the fix you can come to the fix
and learn from us there and there's a
lot of resources out there that people
can take advantage of and I think if
they just stick to the basics the basic
principles of Islam trying to find the
answers to that they won't have a
problem learning what they need to learn
and stick to the masjid that was the
thing that changed my life going to the
masjid and learning that knowledge
proceeds words and deeds you know people
are going to have to look out for our
show we're going to have to give some
since you're in the martial arts i'm in
the martial art yeah we can maybe show
some some safety the self defense tips
and we'll do a show on this what do you
think she'll out you shall all got a lil
make it exciting okay look forward to
having you back okay thanks for coming
thanks for letting me come on your show
thank you very much for coming up I
really appreciate it may Allah reward
you I mean that's all the time we have
in
you've heard him say stick to the basics
is very simple start off with asking the
One God the creator of the heavens and
earth and Eric we say Allah and Aramaic
jesus said aloha that one guy who
created the heavens and earth and
everything in it asking for the guidance
and then keep it simple keep it simple
go back to the basics if you're Muslim
already you have the verbatim word of
God the Quran and you have the authentic
teachings of the lasting final message
sent the man kind of problem peace be
upon him his Sinha his way the same way
if you were living during the time of
Moses you follow what he was given and
he was the teacher he was the message of
teaching you how to get close to God
same thing during a time of Jesus he was
the teacher teaching you how to get
closer but today we have the last and
final message send a man kind of problem
having peace be upon him and then you
have his companions they understood this
way of life the best so you have the
blueprint the formula the verbatim word
of God the authentic student of the last
final messenger from Muhammad peace be
upon him and how his companions
understood it they ate slept lived with
the last final messenger this is a
simple way of life all the information
is there you just got to take the time
continue to come back here to the Dean
show and inshallah you get to benefit
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be unto you
you